as we're at home more often it's a great
time to upgrade your
hva system to something cooler hvac
hvac i say hva system that's what i said
in a hotel college
okay in hotel college yeah okay yeah
rocky caught up with windows aires
air conditioning and heating to see what
upgrades they have to offer
step one get an hvac system from buenos
aires air conditioning and heating
step two let them install it step three
get your maintenance done and step four
get your upgrade
well the regular system is what the
house requires as a basic
um you know just the the parts or the or
the equipment like a split system you
got the coil the furnace and the
condenser that's your your simple system
or the packaging on the roof when we
talk about upgraded systems
we're talking about um like sort of like
mods that we can put into
into the air conditioners um one of
those mods would be like
a humidifier per se if you want your
house a little bit more
humid uh especially now in the heat
in vegas which is dry you can set it to
80 humidity 60 humidity and then the
house will get to that point that's one
of the mods
uh one of the things that the people do
ask a lot for
are are the new not so new but people
are being used it's really just more
the wi-fi thermostats mods meaning
modifications and honestly i know i'm
not the only one who could use the
humidifier upgrade in this dry heat
the mod most of the buenos aires
customers ask for though
is a wi-fi thermostat these are the
thermostats that you can actually
control from your phone from anywhere as
long as there's internet
in in it's a very nice tool sometimes
people leave the house and
they forget to shut turn down the ac or
turn it up
when they're not there so they can go
from their phone and do it or even
program it from their phone it's super
simple super easy
now imagine a home with one air
conditioner and a thermostat in each
room set at their own desired
temperatures
this upgrade is called a zoning system
but i'll let the expert explain
zoning is huge it's something very very
convenient for
for any home the way the zoning works is
you have a
one air conditioner with many
thermostats a zoning system is one of
the more popular upgrades
and it can actually save you money you
can keep any room
at any temperature at the same time for
instance
one can be at 70 degrees the one can be
at 78 degrees
all with one system last but certainly
not least the filtration system is a
vital upgrade to your hvac system
your regular filter will protect the
equipment when you
put something upgraded it will actually
not protect only the unit but the people
in the home
with with asthma or allergies or or
things
now you have a filtration system that
could leave your house as a surgical
room if you wanted to
and that's not it here are a few more
mods carlos and the team offer
uv lights which will protect the from
bacterias and viruses
and and mold and things like that and
also
another one of the mods will be aired
that replacing the
old air ducts for something newer with
more insulation
thicker insulation which is what's
requiring an output coat from the city
the air will be protected inside the
attic from the heat well you've got
options at buenos aires air conditioning
and heating so enjoy that upgrade
and stay cool for more information call
702-794-2727 or head to buenos
airesac.com
they offer special financing for new
units and filters
las vegas now will